Modern Warfare 2 has made some important
changes to its third person mode and
Silent Hill is teasing the future of the
series
the release date for Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 is quickly approaching and Now
Call of Duty's Instagram has revealed a
major change to the third person mode
the post revealed some top tips for
playing Modern Warfare 2 and confirmed
that a post beta update to third person
mode will require that only Scopes over
four times Zoom will activate first
person ads this change is a significant
upgrade over the beta version of the
mode as no matter which optic was used
aiming down sights would automatically
switch the view to first person mode
this consonant switching was a bit
jarring and the only way to avoid the
view change was to hip-fire weapons now
players will be able to aim with a
traditional third person Style with
first person view only necessary when
using a scope with magnification of four
times or more Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 will release on October 28th
across PS4 PS5 Xbox One Xbox series X
and S and PC those with digital
pre-orders of the game will receive
Early Access to Modern War Warfare 2's
campaign starting sometime on October
20th and if you're really into spooky
games then you're going to want to make
sure to pay attention to the day before
the early campaign drops on October 19th
couldn't do numbers for a second the
future of the Silent Hill franchise has
been foggy as the town itself for some
time now but the fog will soon clear as
Konami has announced a silent hill
transmission for October 19th at 2PM
Pacific Time 5 PM Eastern according to a
Sunday tweet from the official Konami
Twitter account the latest updates for
the Silent Hill series are set to be
discussed during the transmission no
specific details have been announced and
we don't even know if it will focus on
games or another type of media this
announcement comes weeks after a
previously unknown game silent hilled a
short message appeared on a Korean
ratings board rumors have spiraled about
a new game in the franchise since
earlier this year including one that
said multiple Silent Hill projects were
in the works and lastly let's talk
Gotham Knights after announcing a
four-player co-op mode will be coming to
the game next month Warner Bros Montreal
has shared another piece of less
exciting news the game will run at 30
frames per second on console with no
performance mode option the announcement
was made via the official Gotham nice
Discord server by The Game's executive
producer and the fact that this is real
is making me wonder why the game isn't
just a PS4 slash Xbox One game those
versions were scrapped yet it feels like
we're still getting them in a way hit
the comments and let me know what you
think of today's stories make sure to
drink some water
foreign